Привет. Итак, у нас есть прото-персоны, профили поведения, job to be done, раздражители,
инсайты. Следующий шаг — это проверить, держится ли наши предположения, прежде чем тащить их впереди.
Для этого есть техника — агент входит в роль персоны и отвечает от её лица. Вы задаёте вопросы — он
отвечает в контексте конкретного человека. Звучит просто, но тут важно понять, зачем это делать и где
границы такого подхода. Хорошая аналогия — это скетч или набросок. Вы скетчите не для того,
чтобы получить финальный дизайн. Вы делаете набросок, чтобы думать. Рука рисует, голова замечает
проблемы, которые не видны в абстракции. С симуляцией интервью — то же самое. Вы разговариваете не
для того, чтобы получить валидацию или накопать какие-то очень глубокие инсайты. Вы разговариваете,
чтобы обнаружить дыры в собственном мышлении. Конкретно это решает три задачи. Первое — проверить
допущение. Вы написали персоне, например, бесит, что нельзя сделать что-то в два клика. Окей,
но когда вы описываете своё решение этой проблемы и слышите в ответ: «А зачем? Я обычно делаю это
через другой способ», вы понимаете, что допущение было неточным. Вы приписали персоне проблему,
которая на самом деле для неё вообще не приоритетна. Второе — это поиск edge cases. Вы описываете фичу,
персона спрашивает: «А что будет, если у меня будет, например, 50 проектов, а не 3?» Или «А если я в метро,
например, без интернета?» Это сценарии, которые вы не прописывали, но которые логически вытекают из
контекста персона. Агент их генерирует, потому что рассуждает от лица человека с конкретными условиями.
Третье — заточить вопросы для реального кастдева. Если вы потом пойдёте разговаривать с живыми людьми,
а я рекомендую всё-таки это делать, у вас уже будут отточены вопросы. Вы прогнали их на симуляции,
увидели, какие из них дают пустые ответы, какие вскрывают интересные. Соответственно,
реальное интервью у вас пройдёт продуктивнее. Понятно, что это не замена кастдева с живыми людьми,
но вы в любом случае рассуждаете от лица персоны, когда проектируете, прикидываете,
как она пойдёт по экрану, что нажмёт, где застрянет. Это всё здорово, но вы ограничены всё-таки личным
опытом. Агент сделает это точнее и посмотрит с разных сторон на задачу. И более того, он не знает
ваш дизайн заранее и не склонен подтверждать ваши решения по инерции. Как обычно, я подготовил
для вас директиву и в ней указал правила поведения. Ключевое — агент не подыгрывает. Если ваша
идея не решает проблему персоны, он скажет. Если фича ему не нужна, он ответит «Зачем мне это?». Без таких
строгих указаний упражнение превращается просто в самоутешение. Итак, давай запустим директиву.
Укажем сразу нашу primary персону. Так, кто у меня будет главной персоной? Ну, наверное,
Антон, разработчик. Давай выберу его. И так, закину сразу в чатик. И главной персоной у меня
Антон. Поэтому я пишу ему «Войди в роль Антона из файла персоны.md». Всё, закидываем и ждём,
пока он войдёт в роль. Всё, готов. Я Антон, 28 лет, бэкенд-разработчик на фрилансе.
Задавай вопросы. Можем начинать наше интервью. У моей персоны Антона есть свой pet-проект,
который он на серваке держит. Поэтому давай, например, спрошу его: «Расскажи, как у тебя обычно
выглядит процесс, когда тебе нужно катнуть свой проект на сервер». Здесь у него получился довольно
развернутый ответ. Вот он говорит: «Обычно это выглядит так, у меня есть новая идея». Написал бота.
Захожу в Headsner, жму «Добавить сервер». Выбираю Ubuntu. Ubuntu действительно, по-моему,
чаще всего для всяких разных вообще нужд используют. Вот это я нигде не отмечал. Можно это себе
пометить. Также тут рассказано, что он ставит докер на сервер. Не буду объяснять, что такое докер. На
самом деле, даже я его использую, когда именно вопросами разработки занимаюсь. Поэтому уже
сейчас возникла идея: можно во время формирования своего сервера, я знаю, что так уже делают,
предлагают сразу туда предустанавливать различные терминалы и прочее. Мы вот можем,
например, предложить докер сразу на сервер поставить, если он в любом случае будет это делать. Можно
добавить такую опцию. Также себе, например, помечаем. Также он подсветил проблему, что он делает
часто что-то для клиентов, поэтому ему было бы удобнее сразу на клиента это все оформлять, чтобы он в
в дальнейшем оплачивал. А там, когда серверки заводишь, нужен паспорт, кредитка, верификация и так далее.
Это полезный тоже инсайд. Ну и проблемы с биллингом из-за того, что это немецкий сервис.
Вот. Можно дальше задавать ему вопросы. Вот он подсветил ряд проблем. Давай спросим у него, какими инструментами ты сейчас для этого всего пользуешься. Вот. Здесь, опять же, у него ряд проблем. Он нас засыпает своими техническими терминами. Вот, например, если речь идет про мониторинг, он говорит: "Вот перестал отвечать, мне в Telegram приходит уведомление. Я сам это настроил через
Health Check". То есть, ему пришлось настраивать это самостоятельно. Мы, опять же, можем в своем сервисе предлагать это уже в качестве фичи. Это не так сложно делается. Ну и на самом деле, у нас, по-моему, в таблице вот этих фичей уже была такая штука отмечена. Ну и в целом, здесь он перечисляет инструменты, с которыми он взаимодействует. Здесь уже можно подумать о том, чтобы интегрировать как-то связь с ними. Здесь уже можно подумать о том, чтобы настроить интеграции с ними в своем продукте.
Дальше тут. Я у него спросил: "Если бы ты мог изменить одну вещь, чтобы это было?" Он жалуется на верификацию, привязку карт и так далее. С точки зрения законов, наверное, эту штуку сложно решить.
Но, вот он подсветил, например: "У меня есть деньги в USDT на кошельке в Телеге. Почему бы нам не предложить ему гипотетически такой сервис, который позволяет тебе сервак свой разворачивать сразу с Телеграма?
Там же его мониторить, там же оплачивать с внутреннего кошелька в USDT вот эту услугу.
Давай предложим ему такое. Может быть, он что-то интересное в этой идее подсветит для нас.
В Телеграме сейчас уже делают внутри прямо приложение. Почему бы вот такое не предложить?
Не знаю, насколько с технической точки зрения это реализуемо, но предложить ему можно.
Так, предложил ему. Он проявил интерес, но подсветил различные штуки. Вот, например, если я захочу SSH в сервер, как мне это даст мини-ап?
Если сейчас у меня монитор 27 дюймов, то как это уложится в мини-ап в Телеграме, в Телефоне?
Как дополнительная точка входа - это очень круто. Там с метро, с телефона, уведомления - удобно.
Но все-таки основную панель он хочет видеть в вебе. В целом, думаю, это да, понятно.
То есть, как фичу это можно рассмотреть, но он точно не предпочел бы вот Телеграм мини-ап полноценному веб-приложению.
Ну и предположим, все-таки мы там пушим в этот продукт то, что у нас есть и Телеграм мини-ап, и какой-то веб-интерфейс.
И вот спросим у него, допустим, ты начал пользоваться вот нашим продуктом.
Что заставило бы тебя уйти обратно к тому, чем пользуешься сейчас?
Итак, что он подсветил?
Первое - это даунтайм, то есть время до уведомления о том, что с серваком, если с ним что-то не так.
Вот, например, у Хэтснер достаточно высокая надежность.
Он пишет, что за полтора года был один даунтайм на 10 минут, и они сразу написали, что случилось.
Это вызывает доверие.
Также криптохостинг без репутации.
Да, нашим пользователям удобнее с криптой взаимодействовать.
Тем не менее, если нашего продукта пока нет, мы только его выкатываем, то ну как это выглядит?
Ноунейм хостинг, который принимает только в крипте, достаточно странно.
Поэтому здесь, хоть мы и отвечаем на запрос пользователей, но вопрос доверия стоит достаточно остро.
Ну и дальше тут гибкость, коммерциализация и так далее.
В общем, болтать так с ним можно очень долго.
Копать, копать, копать.
Потом взять другую персону, тоже поискать какие-то вопросы, позадавать.
Это прям хороший инструмент брейншторма.
После того, как закончили, пишем, выйди из роли и подведи итоги по нашему разговору.
Что подтвердилось, что нового, какие edge cases, где противоречия, какие рекомендации для дизайна.
И сохрани все в интервью, Антон МД.
Итак, файлик готов.
В конечном итоге у нас четыре раздела.
Первое - то, что подтвердилось.
Второе - новые инсайты.
Далее - противоречия с нашими гипотезами.
И рекомендации для дизайна.
Файлик у нас сохраняется в проект, и агент в дальнейшем будет использовать его при приоритизации и генерации PRD.
Весь диалог у нас занял минут пять.
Не нужно часовое интервью.
Конечно, опять же, это живое интервью не заменяет по количеству глубины, наверное, в беседе.
Нам тут достаточно поймать два-три момента, где наши предположения не выдерживают проверки.
Ну или в ходе беседы придумать что-то новое и посмотреть, как на это отреагирует персона.
Этого достаточно, чтобы скорректировать курс до того, как вы начнете проектировать, ну и в принципе по брейншторме.
Итак, в качестве домашнего задания.
Ваша задача - провести разговор с вашей primary персоной.
Попытаться покопаться, придумать, как ваш проект можно улучшить.
Послушать те боли, которые он вам выдает.
И попытаться как-то продукт развить.
Посмотреть, как он это встретит.
И в конечном итоге собрать все в конечный файлик.
И в конечном итоге собрать все в файлик интервью, нижнее подчеркивание, там имя вашей персоны.
И посмотреть, что нового удалось нарыть.
Директива будет, как обычно, в материалах к уроку.
Формат сдачи - это скриншот этого документа.
И какое-то ваше краткое описание того, что интересного вам удалось нарыть.
И что нового вы узнали из сферы своего продукта.
Именно через призму вашей персоны.
На этом все. Увидимся в следующем уроке.
До встречи!